[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
manchmal will ich was packen und dann
habe ich keine idee was ich machen soll
als er wirklich und manchmal sprudelt
vor kreativität und heute habe ich mir
gedacht nämlich das mikrofon und stadt
jetzt eine kleine umfrage im büro und
das was man am meisten zusagt dass
pakistan als auch kommt man mit jungs
ich will heute was backen aber ich weiß
nicht was habt ihr eine idee meiner
kräfte habe ich schon was liegt da haben
schon sichtbar so stieg das sind so
viele wie bei meiner bestreitet dann
gemacht das für die macher durch dritte
[Musik]
es bleibt was ist das
für den hefeteig verwende ich einen
würfel hefe 30 milliliter warmes wasser
80 500 gramm mehl 2 120 milliliter milch
einen teelöffel salz 2 eigelbe und 100
gramm weiche butter für den hefeteig
nämlich jetzt erst die hefe da kommt
wasser dazu jetzt kann ich die hefe
einfach dem wasser auflösen
es kommen die zutaten hier einfach in
die rührschüssel ich arbeite jetzt mit
der küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt
natürlich auch alles per hand verkneten
vom alle anderen zutaten rein also mehl
zucker salz ganz wichtig bei hefeteig
damit der hilft eigentlich überhaupt
schmeckt muss auf jeden fall salz dran
die lauwarme mensch dann die eigelbe da
kann ich jetzt hier den hefeteig einfach
schön geschmeidig verkneten lassen
[Musik]
so sieht der teig jetzt super aus
erklärt jetzt auch nicht mehr perfekt
jetzt nehme ich einfach ein bisschen
back trend in die hand wohl den teig
kurz raus jetzt einfach zu einer schönen
kugel zusammen formen die schüssel noch
bisschen fetten detail kugel reinsetzen
ein bisschen besprühen abdecken und dann
für etwa eine halbe stunde zu stunde
aufgehen lassen bis sich der teig schön
verdoppelt hat jetzt ist der hefeteig
richtig schön aufgegangen und ich nehme
ein bisschen mühe geben jetzt hier auch
meine silikon matschie ich liebe einfach
hefeteig
deswegen kann man jetzt die wachowski
genau richtig außerdem habe ich sie
gefragt was nicht wünscht gesagt er
wünscht sich mal war zu spät
also mache ich dass wir das ja mal und
für die anderen so und jetzt hier
einfach schön zerteilen die größe könnt
ihr im prinzip selbst bestimmen
ich mache jetzt 16 teile deswegen
halbwegs dann immer zuerst und dann wird
der rest noch mal geschüttelt und dann
noch mal halbiert und dann passt die
werden jetzt hier zu kugeln gefahren
einfach immer schön von außen nach innen
mit den fingern formen so dann wenn
außen schön glatt ist umdrehen und
nochmal schön rund wirken
[Musik]
das teilen glaubt er so schon ganz gut
aber trotzdem muss ich sie immer noch zu
kontrollieren
[Musik]
es habe nur ein gramm und geschlecht
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
die kugel lege ich ziehe direkt auf
einem backblech
das habe ich bereits mit dauer bugs
coole belegt
[Musik]
die kugeln sind jetzt alle gemacht die
drücke ich leicht flach und dann kann
ich schon die füllung zu bereiten das
wird jetzt eine quarks füllung für die
cvag füllung verwende ich 500 gramm
quark 41 prozent fettanteil zwei eier 60
50 gramm stecke etwas vanille extrakt
und 30 ich finde den fehler ich habe
jetzt eine schüssel volk war und habe
mit verschlüsselung das ganze zu
verrühren verliert das passt hier
niemals mehr war ein
ich nehme mir größere das wird lustig
geworden
so jetzt einfach den quark mit allen
zutaten verrühren also eier dazu stärken
zur bindung manche nehmen da
vanillepudding pulver braucht man aber
nicht denn vanillepudding pulver ist
einfach nur stecke mit vanille oder
vanille aroma und einfach bisschen
farbstoff also nehmen wir es die eier
die stärke und richtig ist wenn in der
extrakt und dann mache ich jetzt einfach
schön glatt rühren
es hat niemals in die schüssel gepasst
er war etwa und wenn dann wäre die
hälfte
daneben gegangen bei mir ist die masse
schon relativ flüssig deswegen lasse ich
jetzt hier die milch einfach weg wie
kommen was unternehmen sie dazu ich habe
ja drin und stärke das passt das macht
schön cremig und gestalt ist perfekt
[Musik]
ist voll schön aus mit dem man in
luftiger wie ein wanderpokal und jetzt
kommt diese füllung in dieser kugeln
rein
das fragt man sich vielleicht wie zwar
mache ich das jetzt so ich nehme ein
bisschen mehl schütte es hier auf die
arbeitsplatte beziehungsweise silikon
mutter tun gibt es ein glas hinein und
ist glas hat einfach in kleinerem
durchmesser als die kreise
und dann mache ich damit jetzt hier eine
öffnung rein
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich einfach den mittleren
eis portionieren und fülle damit die
cvag füllung 1
[Musik]
dass ich jetzt hier nochmal kommt stehen
und wenn ich alle gefüllt habe streiche
ich sie mit einer mischung aus eigelb
und mit und dann können sie gebacken
werden und am besten macht es so dass
ihr das loch hier in der mitte die
öffnung etwas weiter
dann passt nämlich mehr füllung rein
[Musik]
und wenn sie dann gestrichen sind könnt
ihr sie entweder noch mal eine halbe
stunde stehen lassen zum aufgehen oder
ihr schickt sie einfach in einem alten
backofen und während der backofen
dann nämlich aufheizt können die diva
tricky nochmal aufgehen so mache ich das
jetzt so spart man sich auch ein
bisschen zeit
[Musik]
in den kalten ofen stellen offen
anschalten und backen
[Musik]
hier war zu spielen sie jetzt fertig
babuschka hat hätte ich kaum die jungs
probiert ihr auch kommt und sehen sie
aus wie original so da sind sie noch mal
die freunde aus der türkei aus
deutschland in der türkei ist es sei
übrigens was du willst und zwar sehen
sozusagen in der türkei ist ein
riesenhype was die jungs hier machen
sie kommen aus dortmund richtig machen
das machen wir nicht machen genau dort
ja machen sie die probe ist ihr glück an
mir und ist eigentlich ein kumpel von
siamak ihr kennt euch wie lange schon
und bevor das jahrmarkt bei uns
angefangen hat sie ja auch so aus ich
glaube der ist die amag ist auch
auseinandergegangen
ja ich kann aber auch verstehen warum
ich meine hinter so übertrug spiels
rennen aber ehrlich aus die jeden tag
die matte stand dass seine mutter und
wir weiter zu hause genau was ihr profil
häuser ernährung sieht bisschen anders
aus oder da ist quatsch
jetzt ist für heute ist wieder frei so
schön hoch prozent zur feier des tages
also das was sie heute ist ist dann
praktisch day für die nächsten drei
monate für den nächsten ein oder zwei
okay wir machen es aber wieder gut dafür
dass ich euch jetzt quelle dürfte ja mal
den murat quellen sehr gerne sehr gut
und ich nehme mal mit einem jahr im
monat an sich aus wie ihr oder mit drei
monate aber er ermöglicht drei monaten
aus mehr greifen ja in drei monaten auf
jeden fall was ordentliches jahr den
bauch würden wir auf jeden fall wegen
bekommen ja ich habe keinen rauch
gesehen
ihr habt echt von mir die erlaubnis ist
denn murat drei monate mitzunehmen aber
wir brauchen jetzt ein versprechen von
dir dass du das aber wirklich
durchziehen schließt keine wird es auch
keinen karies kann ich mein leben aber
nicht mathematisch dieser problematik
bay und sehr marco morath ihr dürft dann
einen ausflug machen alles klar da darf
ich jetzt froh merkel kam probierte ich
wusste gar nicht dass ich immer prozent
haben kommt dass ich hab nicht mal
blitzschnell noch drauf ich habe keinen
süßen schnee drauf ist muss ich ja sagen
wir schon die polen ist für uns die ja
und dann sind wir die deutsche quark
taschen also sowie ungefähr wie pudding
treffen nur halt in die kartusche
schmeckt wie wieder ein papa ist iraner
deine mutter ist was hinten und ein
bisschen deutschland geworden weil die
perfekte match habe ich sagen
[Musik]
ein weg ja diese woche oder kirsch
platzer oder irgendwelche rahmen rahmen
sitzen oder so ich denke ich kann jetzt
trainieren gehen ihr blut proteine genug
proteine für heute
falls ihr die wachowski auch nach machen
wollt findet ihr das rezept auf 6 -
blog.de dann macht ihr am besten nach
und danach geht ihr zu den fremdkörper
so gemacht die workouts und dann seid
ihr dran und ich werde jetzt die was ein
bisschen trainieren nach meinen
trainingsplan die gehens molekularen und
ihr nehmt ihnen über aber wir sind super
geschmeckt wirklich schmeckt es weg
danke bis zum nächsten mal
und falls ihr wollt dass ich öfter so
eine umfrage mache im büro und dann
wunsch rezepte machen
dann schreibt sie in die kommentare
genau wir sehen uns gleich auf dem kanal
von der schwelle das mit meinem workout
ich bin gespannt
vorsicht schon verstehen hocker
[Musik]
ski sind so nett das sind so viele wie
bei meiner bestreitet sind gemacht
danke